l'accident s'est produit vers 10 heures
à hauteur de la commune de vaux jaucourt
d'après la gendarmerie une voiture
circulait à contresens
elle a percuté un camion de pompiers de
la caserne de pont de roide en arrêt
cardio-respiratoire le conducteur a été
déclaré décédé sur la part de la pop
l'intercepter avancé qu' il venait juste
de rentrer sur l'autre rouge mais comme
on est à 800 mètres dindane échangeurs
libre il se peut très bien que il
sortait de ses d'échangeurs lime et bat
pour faire 1 800 m ça va très très vite
dans l'autre véhicule impliqué trois
pompiers ont été blessés dont la
conductrice a été blessée grièvement
héliporté vers l'hôpital de besançon la
circulation sur l'a36 a été totalement
interrompue dans les deux sens elle a
repris vers 11h15 dans le sens besançon
montbéliard montbéliard mais elle est
toujours fermée dans le sens montbéliard
besançon